you know we've seen the images we've
shown shown them to you on this program
of mass graves one body being tossed on
top of another they have their own
territorial ambitions in china namely
taiwan it'll react to that much more
south carolina senator lindsey graham
you know i keep reading reading that you
want
the u.s to put boots on the ground and
you told me because i do not want that
and i asked you and i said under no
circumstances can we get that clear
tonight
yeah i do not want any american boots on
the ground in the ukraine i don't want a
no-fly zone but if there's the use of
chemical weapons by putin against the
ukrainian people i would support a
no-fly zone because that would be uh
breaking every uh war crime rule in the
book and the ban on chemical weapons
would be nothing if we didn't act with a
no-fly zone but right now no boots on
the ground no fly zone uh china china is
trying to bail out putin if putin loses
china loses so
to the body administration don't make
the same mistake with china you did
russia if you believe the chinese are
going to help putin survive by providing
military equipment economic assistance
by the way they backfill the credit card
problem that happened when mastercard
and visa pulled out of
russia china's credit card system took
over put on the table for china to read
the sanctions that will come your way if
you help putin i will help you as a
republican mr president president biden
if you will write down sanctions
secondary sanctions against china what
will happen to the chinese economy if
they bail out this war criminal putin i
will be your best ally in the united
states senate write it down now so china
can read it because nobody believes you
unless you write it down
i'm not sure if he remembers your name
now we watch large ballistic missiles
slam into our base in iraq fired by iran
uh we got a warning this weekend from
china that the worst consequences for
any country that supports the taiwan
military and it seems and may correct me
if i'm wrong senator all the all that
vladimir putin has to do is mention
nuclear weapons biological chemical
weapons um and and joe backs off joe
vetoed the migs from poland himself he
made that decision according to all the
reports so my question is what is biden
willing to do
against all of the in every one of these
cases because i don't see a decisive
president that has any type of doctrine
if you will we always ask well what what
is the reagan doctrine the trump
doctrine the bush doctrine what is the
biden doctrine
bow down and pray and we slow and hope
for the best
yeah apparently slow and indecisive is
his reaction but here's an idea
if you believe zelinski knows what he's
doing and the ukrainian people are
heroic in their efforts to protect their
country from a russian invasion give
them what they say they need i'm not
asking for boots on the ground i'm not
asking for a no-fly zone but i spoke to
the ukrainian ambassador at length today
and here's what she told me
they can fight on the ground they're
holding their own on the ground they
desperately need some help to control
their skies they want the mig-29s they
believe if they had the migs they could
really push back against uh the air
power of russia there well senator hang
on a second 100 203 yeah
all right so
we're giving them javelins we're giving
them stinger missiles
why can't we give an approval for
fighter jets why not
well here's what president biden says
that's an offensive weapon my god
how many americans are worried about
giving the ukrainians the ability to go
on offense this idea they will take a
squadron of mig-29s and invade russia
ukraine would do that is stupid and
crazy and it's just a reason to deny
them the help
that they want because biden's afraid of
putin here's what happened
it was okay for poland to give the migs
we were going to green light it i'm
confident that the putin administration
the putin government called up by and
said if you do that all bets are off and
we fold it like a cheat suit cheat suit
so here's what i want you to understand
what should we do help the ukrainians
with a reasonable request give them the
migs give them air defense capability
they don't have and if you can
neutralize or at least level out the air
power that russia has against ukraine i
think uh ukraine can win on the ground
victory for ukraine is my message here
tonight let's help them achieve victory
all right senator lindsey graham thank
you we appreciate you being with us